do you remember how we were told time
and again that it was president trump
damaging the integrity of our cherished
institutions
is the president threatening the
long-standing independence of the
justice department
the latest really episode in the
president's long-term campaign to
undermine
uh the russia investigation the
department of justice etc the fbi
look the uh justice department is under
a
shelling from the the white house it's
like london 1941 there a full-throated
assault on the rule of law
undermining the department of justice
undermining the fbi in ways that are
just
shocking shocking well now the shoe is
squarely on the other foot think about
what we've just learned in the past 48
hours
mccabe the former deputy fbi director
has asked for congressional immunity
for any further congressional testimony
according to abc news the doj
inspector general report finds that
comey was insubordinate
and criticizes his handling of the
clinton email investigation
the report also casts serious doubt on
the former attorney general loretta
lynch's role
in that same investigation particularly
her tarmac meeting with bill clinton
let's discuss these amazing new falls
from grace with former secret service
agent
dan bongino of nra tv president of
judicial watch tom fenton
and jeff beatty who served in the fbi
and cia let's start with you tom
it is quite something to hear that
litany of sound bites with the
grand exaggeration from you know it's
like the bombing of
london in 1940 come on i mean what what
we've seen in this inspector general
report just the little dribs and drabs
we've seen so far
is an fbi that was mishandling this
investigation
not consulting with superiors and
apparently just defying
internal protocol and how they handle
these matters yeah president trump
inherited a terribly corrupt leadership
at the fbi
and he cleaned house by firing comey
this ig report confirms essentially it
looks like
that he did the right thing ironically
mr rosenstein came to the same
conclusion and excoriating
mr comey's handling of the clinton email
investigation
not so much the sham investigation
itself but the fact is that it was a
sham investigation rather confront it
directly
he attacked hillary clinton to distract
from the fact that he was protecting her
what a despicable act by him and the ig
tore him apart
dan let's go to you you've been
extremely passionate
on this issue from the very beginning
what are these developments that we've
learned today and again
these are just the initial leaks that
we've heard with this
ig report seeming seems to be delayed
and delayed and delayed
a lot of comment from people i guess who
were mentioned and democrats republicans
able to comment
perhaps it'll be changed but your
initial reaction of what we're hearing
well it looks like jim comey's going to
be exposed for the holier than now phony
that he was
laura listen he hid this investigation
from congress
for eight months now just so everybody's
clear on this
there is a protocol for quarterly
briefings to congress about
sensitive investigations comey even
acknowledges that
in a hearing up on the hill and then
they ask him quarterly every three
months this isn't difficult for anybody
to understand
he hides it for eight months they ask
him representative elise stefanik mr
comey why did you hide the investigation
from congress for eight months you're
never going to believe this you know
what he says
because it was sensitive after
acknowledging that they brief congress
every three months
because of sensitive investigations of
course i'm talking about the
investigation of donald trump
comey is being exposed here this was
really horrendous leadership
and i really hope this ig report gets
the truth out there
jeff uh your former experience uh at fbi
cia the rank and file agents at the fbi
you know they don't make a ton of money
they work really hard
a lot of them put their lives in danger
every day
what do they think i mean it's kind of a
generic
catch-all question but i always try to
put myself in their shoes what are they
thinking when they
see this circus around this hillary
email investigation and then the
supposed collusion
the russia and the trump campaign that
seems totally non-existent
with informants moving in and out of
london and dates not matching up
what do you think is going through their
minds well you know they have to be
disappointed you know
comey i don't believe he ever was an fbi
agent you know he's been an attorney
and he's had some appointed jobs so he's
not really come up through the ranks
contrast that to somebody like over at
cia gina haspel who's came up through
the ranks
um but you know one of the underlying
things here that people are asking that
i talk to is
where are the whistleblowers where are
the rank and file
whistleblowers here and you know one of
the reasons why
there are not rank and file
whistleblowers coming forward is
there's a pay system in the fbi you
alluded to the fact that they don't get
the best base pay but there is a system
that rewards
them with an additional 25 percent of
their base pay
it used to be called administratively
uncontrollable overtime
and then it became leap law enforcement
availability pay
and what boils down to is fbi agents
have to certify
and supervisors have to certify that
additional time has been worked
basically 50 hour weeks or more
sometimes these these corners are cut a
great book is out there called fraud
fighters written by a guy named wells
who was a
former fbi agent he talks about actual
fraud that was conducted
and then supervisors certified that yeah
this time was worked
and and that's what this is all getting
too much in the weeds for me jeff but i
that you're saying they're not
whistleblowers because they're afraid
they're going to get doc pay i mean tom
yeah remember they had to sign these
extra non-disclosure agreements they
already were committed to not disclosing
information about these investigations
and they put the fear god into them by
forcing the sign these
extraordinary non-disclosure agreements
look i think the most important thing
about this ig leak is that it undermines
the mueller investigation
into the alleged obstruction of justice
supposedly that trump committed in
firing comey
it shows that trump was very much day
one
he should have been gone day one he was
a disaster he should
never have been kept on that was the
only that's like one of the few things i
think
trump could have done differently this
was the most first month the most
significant anti-corruption act by
president recent memory getting rid of
jesus and he's being confirmed
he needs to be what is mueller
investigating now the firing of
dan bongino why is rod rosenstein
still supervising mueller when he is
going to be a witness he is a witness
having signed one of those fisa warrants
that did not reveal that hillary
and her campaign paid for that steele
dossier i mean
lindsey graham's been all over this and
apparently he said if deemed appropriate
i will recuse myself my goodness he
shouldn't be supervising mueller
laura not only that not only did
rosenstein sign one of the fisa warrants
to spy on members of the trump team
he's a material witness in the firing of
jim comey
which the democrats have alleged was the
greatest sin of the trump presidency
despite comey's obvious incompetence
rosenstein's a two-fer
he's implicated in spy gate and he's
implicated in the special counsel
because he's the one who writes the memo
about the firing of comey how he is
still acting as the deputy ag
is one of the great mysteries of my 43
years on this planet yeah i mean
he was a he was though a bad appointment
by
jeff sessions you're the deputy in these
departments i worked at the
transportation department
education department and in the white
house in the last couple years the
reagan administration and the deputy
position
and the under secretary positions are so
important if you have bad people or
people like wet themselves the first
time there's controversy you're going to
be in big trouble especially at the
justice department guys
i want all of you jeff i want you to
react to paul ryan today in his
weekly press conference seemed to jump
on the trade gowdy bandwagon
when asked about spygate let's watch
right before the recess you said in a
briefing that trengalli
came out afterwards and said that he's
more convinced the fbi did exactly what
my television citizens
would want them to do do you agree with
craig yeah normally i don't like to
comment on classified briefings um
let me say it this way i think chairman
gowdy's initial assessment is accurate
i think uh but we have some more digging
to do
well that's an understatement we still
have lots of documents and a lot of
months that are missing
jeff uh no spy i guess we can call it
informant mole
or a lure uh what are your what's your
reaction to that
well my reaction is that this has always
been a
two different approaches when the
democratic apparatus was
attempted to be penetrated by people
outside this country
the fbi went to them and warned them and
said hey let's work together to make
sure that doesn't happen on your servers
that is not the way they handled the
republican side of the coin they instead
decided to go ahead and
call an entrapment if you want run an
operation in there but they sure didn't
go into them as
american citizens and saying hey listen
we have some foreign entities trying to
penetrate this and trying to
corrupt the process they handed the
republicans handled them differently
than they did the democrats and there's
just no excuse for that
yeah so much for the defensive briefings
guys thanks so much